Speaker 1: On the other side of this, I want to
read a little bit from this Daily Beast op ed
that is. In line with the behavior
of Tucker Carlson as the ringleader
of the white nationalist movement in America. He's
they've been talking about the great replacement
theory for months and months and months,
it's no longer a secret, it's no longer a
dog whistle. They are fully embracing as a party
the great replacement theory and along with it,
white genocide, they call it. They whine about
birth rates. They complain about immigration,
about allowing refugees to come from a
desperate situation in their homelands to
the land of promise, the land of opportunity. They
complain about this, these are these are these are
conspiracy theories and complaints that have been
made for a long time by individuals like the Nazi
forseen punched around the world. Richard Spencer.
Or David Duke or Steve Bannon or Steven Miller.
The list is long, Paul Gosar,
Steve Scalise. Who has said that
he's just like David Duke without all the baggage?
This is the modern Republican Party, Donald Trump.
Is the leader of this Republican Party,
so I want to read from this article,
because there are some great nuggets in here
that people in America need to wake up to.
What did Auburn do that makes him a model worth
emulating for conservatives in the United States?
He transformed Hungary's once promising democracy
into a one party state where he
filled the government and judiciary
with political apparatchiks, attacked
the press and political opponents,
abused his power to enrich himself and his
cronies, promoted anti-Semitic conspiracy theories
against George Soros and constructed a 109 mile
high tech razor wire border fence with Serbia.
Sound familiar? If I had if I had said, what did
Donald Trump do that makes him worth a model worth
emulating and then finished it off, no one except
for the part of the the the border with Serbia,
no one would bat an eye. Because the
Republican Party is now full on authoritarian,
they're not authoritarian
lite, they're anti-democratic.
They're anti-American. Continuing on, Auburn
mobilized his base into giving up their freedoms
by promising he will protect them and their
Hungarian heritage from Muslims, refugees and
immigrants of color and protect them from what
he says are political forces in Europe who want a
replacement of population for ideological or other
reasons. Instead, he says, we Hungarians have a
different way of thinking instead of just numbers.
We want Hungarian children. Migration for us
is surrender. And Tucker Carlson takes to his
Fox News program and does a week long commercial
for this individual as though he is a beacon of
what leadership, political and otherwise should
look like in the world. This is dangerous. It's
dangerous because it is ushering in a new wave
of thinkers, of intellectuals who will
look at this as the new way forward.
Viktor Orban is not that new way forward,
it is reactionary, it is regressive.
It is the opposite of the things that we should
strive for in America, progressive values,
acceptance, diversity, caring for
our fellow citizens, whether they
be citizens of the United States or citizens
of the world who are reaching out in need.
And Tucker Carlson turns his
back. On that idea. Disgusting